one of my favorite unsolved problems in
mathematics maybe it's best to start
with Euler's formula all those formula
tells something about triangle a the
spheres so maybe I have to tell you what
a triangle ade is furious well
intuitively it is a sphere but it is
made combinatorial so that every face is
a triangle so you want to attach bunch
of triangles in such a way that the
entire shape is essentially identical to
a sphere you can continuously move it to
forming make it round so maybe the
easiest example is a simplex so simplex
has four vertices 1 2 3 4 and if you
just look at the boundary of it the
tetrahedron then it is essentially a
sphere you can continuously deform into
a sphere every face of it is a triangle
in fact you see 4 of them 1 2 3 & 4 so
as you can imagine there are many many
different ways to triangulate the sphere
another example maybe it's the second
easiest example is the boundary of an
octahedron it's essentially a sphere and
I can go on maybe the third familiar
example is the boundary of an
icosahedron where I glued together 20
triangles to make us feel so always
formula says something about triangle
eight aspheres he noticed that if you
stare each one of these triangle a the
spheres say the 2-dimensional spheres as
as we are considering now and if you
first count the number of vertices so if
I do the tetrahedron I see four vertices
1 2 3 4 and then I'll going to count the
edges 1 2 3 4 5 6 and then I count the
triangles there are 4 triangles in a
tetrahedron so I'm counting 0
dimensional faces 1 dimensional faces
and 2 dimensional faces so let me call
them F 0 and F 1
and f2 and what wheeler did was to
compute the alternating sum EPS zero
minus f1 plus f2 which is in our case
four minus six plus four which is equal
to two so let me do the same computation
for the octahedron the alternating sum
of the number of faces of various
dimension then I get six minus 12 plus 8
which is equal to 2 as you have guessed
this is a general pattern no matter how
you triangulate your two-dimensional
sphere the alternating sum of the number
of faces is always equal to 2 okay so
that was our last observation so let's
just imagine how this wonderful but
seemingly accidental pattern will
continue in higher dimensions so you can
certainly think about 3-dimensional
spheres instead of two-dimensional
spheres and certainly you can
triangulate them and there are
infinitely many different ways of
triangulating them and you can do the
same now you have four numbers to think
about instead of three you have vertices
edges triangles
and many many tetrahedrons so the
triangle a the spheres in the next
dimension will be a way to make a sphere
by gluing together many of the
tetrahedron
the next dimension is always hard to
imagine so before making the correct
guess let's let's go to even a lower
dimension so that was the picture for
two dimensional spheres but let's this
time imagine one dimensional spheres
triangulated one dimensional spheres so
triangles in one dimensions are supposed
to be just straight lines we know very
well how typical triangulated
one-dimensional spheres look like this
is one triangulated one sphere where I
used five vertices and five edges so my
numbers will be F 0 equals 5 and F 1
equals 5 and the Euler's relation in
this case will look like this and again
the number 0 that we see here is
independent of the triangle ization of
the 1 dimensional sphere that i have
chosen for example if you have used 7
vertices you are forced to use 7 edges
too because you want the entire thing to
be a one dimensional sphere which is a
circle so it the Euler's relation in one
dimension is simply saying that F 0
minus F 1 is 0 so let's go even lower
and think about zero dimensional spheres
so this is a little bit tricky if you
had never thought about zero dimensional
spheres but what is really a sphere a
sphere is supposed to be the something
that lives in our space which consists
of all points that are of the same
distance from the origin or whatever
point that you have chosen so the zero
dimensional sphere should live in a one
dimensional space which is line and if I
collect all points that are of say
distance 1 from the origin then I would
get exactly two point zero dimensional
sphere is two point and that's
well in my sense that's a triangle
ladies fear and there is really one
number f0 the number of vertices and
that number of vertices should be always
2 so in this case the olders formula
will look like at zero equals 2 again
that's right
so I add 2 in dimension zero zero in
dimension one and two in dimension two
so we can imagine what would be the next
number and say in dimension three what
is it going to I guess yeah you should
guess is this gonna oscillate is it
gonna go back to zero yes that is a
correct guess and in fact although it's
hard to imagine three-dimensional
spheres for this particular problem we
can actually test it for our favorite
trying to triangulate the three spheres
because there is a higher dimensional
analog of the tetrahedron so there is
called a simplex sense there is a
simplex in any dimension so if you take
four points in general position in three
space then you get the tetrahedron and
analogously if you take five general
points in four dimensional space then
you will get a simplex and we can kind
of imagine how it would look like
especially if we force it to live in our
familiar three-dimensional space so it
will have five vertices and because the
five points which lives in four space or
in general position every pair of the
vertices will be connected by an edge so
that's how the set of edges are four
dimensional simplex will look like if I
draw it in this piece of paper and
similarly every triple of points that
you see in this picture will form a
triangle because the five points in four
space are in general position and every
for collection of the five points will
form a tetrahedral face of that simplex
so we can compute these numbers F so f 0
is 5 and f 1 will be 5 choose 2 as one
of the binomial coefficients which is 10
and F 2 will be 5 2 3 next entry in
Pascal's triangle and F 3 will be 5
choose 4 which is 5 so let's test our
prediction if you start from 5 subtract
10 add 10 subtract 5 and you get zero
that's right and you can imagine how it
would work and the amazing fact is that
something like this happens for all
triangle ages fears in any dimension you
just see whether you're living in an
even dimensional space or odd
dimensional space and then you know that
no matter how you triangulate a sphere
if you perform this alternating sum
computation you get either 2 or 0 the
number either 0 or 2 depending on the
parity of the dimension is called the
Euler characteristic
it's Dualla characteristic of the sphere
and is independent of the triangle is
asian so that's an amazing fact which
took many many years for mathematicians
to rigorously justify but we know now as
a fact that no matter how you triangle 8
the sphere you always get either 0 or 2
that was great but you may not like this
alternating pattern 0 - 0 - 0 - but
there is a another way of expressing
this pattern that does not care about
the parity of the dimension and this is
our starting point so let me express the
Euler characteristic in another way so
for example let me start from our
obtained heat or an example 6 vertices
twelve edges and eight triangles in the
octahedron and what are going to do next
is to attach a string of ones so let's
to make it a triangular shape and next
I'm going to do something like Pascal's
rule for constructing his triangle but
using subtractions instead of addition
so what do I mean
so I see 1 and 6 here so I'm going to
subtract 1 from 6 and write down 5 below
and I do the same I see 1 and 5 I
subtract 1 from 5 and write down 4 here
and then I look at 5 and 12 and subtract
5 from 12 I have a 7 here I do the same
I get 3 I get 3 and I get 1 this
sequence which you get in the end of
this process is called the H vector of
the triangle ladies fear and as you see
there's a some pattern here it is
palindromic it's 1 3 3 1 but if you read
it from the other direction is again 1 3
3 1 and this was the case for the
octahedron so let's try to see whether
this was an accident or not so let's
maybe try the icosahedron 12 vertices 30
edges 20 triangles attach a string of
ones on the other side of the triangle
and I subtract and complete this
triangle you got 10 here 19 9 here I get
9 here get 1 here again you see the same
pattern if you keep the bottom row
it is palindromic 1 9 9 1 but at least
you can see what's going on on one of
these numbers so let me just focus on
the last one so the first one served up
this is built-in I just wrote down one
here but the fact that one appeared and
the last part was a miracle sort of but
what was happening so I started with F 0
and F 1 and F 2 and how did I get one in
here I subtract one from F zero and I
subtracted F zero minus one from F 1 and
I subtracted this from that and the
assertion is that this is equal to 1 so
if i write the same thing again it is
what we have seen before
the euler's
at least for two dimensional spheres
well as formula is part of a broader
pattern which says that you have this
palindromic sequence at the bottom of
this strange Pascal like triangle well
one thing that people have noticed is
that if you view Ovilus formula as a
part of this broader symmetry then this
dependency on the parity of the
dimension really goes away so let's try
to do a similar game in one dimension up
maybe we do the simplex with 5 vertices
in 4 space and we already have computed
the number of faces
it had 5 vertices 10 edges 10 triangles
and 5 tetrahedron and again I had a long
string of ones on the other side and I
do the subtraction
it's subtract one from five subtract one
from four
subtract 4 from 10 and continue and this
is what I get 1 1 1 1 1
there's a palindromic sequence of very
special kind that's just dual maybe one
or two more examples just to make sure
that the pattern we are seeing here is
not an accident so maybe let's do a
higher dimensional version of the
octahedron number of vertices that's 8
how many edges you need to be a little
bit clever to actually compute this
number and the answer is actually 24 so
f 2 if you count the number of triangles
in this higher-dimensional of tawheed
Rijn you get 32 and if you count the
number of tetrahedrons you get 16 so
let's do the same game this time a
little bit faster 1 1 1 1 1 1 and 7 6 17
5 11 15 4 6 4 1 and that's my end result
in this sequence that you see is what is
known as the H vector of the this
particular triangle disappear but if you
think about at least very small part of
the symmetry which predicts that the
last entry in your H vector should be 1
then again it is the Euler's formula for
this 3-dimensional sphere because think
about how you got this one starting from
the original data you have your F 0 you
have your F 0 minus 1 and this number is
f1 minus f0 plus 1 this number is f2
minus f1 plus f0 x1 and this number here
is f3 minus f2 plus f1 minus f0 plus 1
and the symmetry of the a tractor
dictates that this should be 1 I can
write this again in an equivalent form
saying that the alternating sum of the
number of faces of various dimensions
is zero for this triangulated
three-dimensional sphere we're almost
there so if you think of all as formula
in any dimension as a small part of this
larger symmetry that you see in the H
vector in the bottom row of this
subtraction Pascal triangle then the
dependence on the parity of the
dimension goes away well as formula
really just says that in any dimension
the last entry of this triangle that you
see should be one which is just a very
tiny part of the entire symmetric
it's a highly non obvious but in a
certain sense it's a natural symmetry so
the other numbers are also interesting
and they are Betty numbers of some
higher dimensional space which is not a
sphere but is constructed from a sphere
and the fact that the sequence is
palindromic for example this four here
is equal to the other four that you see
gives you another formula on the number
of faces of various dimensions which is
different from all those former it is
something like Euler's formula but it is
really new but the fact that the H
vector of a triangle ATIS fear is always
palindromic it was discovered then
somewhat justified about hundred years
ago by mathematicians Marsden and Duncan
Somerville they didn't do this they had
a somewhat more complicated way of
expressing this symmetry of what we now
call H vector but later mathematicians
have realized that this is the best way
to understand and I think this
particular way of viewing the symmetry
is due to Richard Stanley who is also
now in this building the sequence that
you started with the sequence that you
put on one side of the triangle which
counts the number of faces of various
dimension they are called the F vector
because we usually call f0 f1 f2 f3 f4
the face and so what and where do we
jump to H well there is something called
the G vector to and it is really
essentially related to
the unsold problem that I promised you
to introduce so this is a fact we know
several different ways of justifying the
fact that this H vector is palindromic
in whatever dimension for whatever
triangle a the sphere that you start
with if you produce H vector in terms of
the number of bases then you always see
this symmetry but from all these
examples that we have executed so far
you see another pattern other than
symmetry so for example think of this
particular H vector one four six four
one another thing that's apparent in the
example is that this sequence increases
up to middle one and four is larger and
six is even larger of course you see the
same sequence going the other way so
this pattern is called a unimodality so
there is a single mode in the sequence
which should happen exactly in the
middle so say in 17 dimensions if you
pick your favorite triangle ATIS fear
living in that dimension write down the
sequence of H numbers say 17 many of
them then you will see the stencil
mobile relation which says that your
sequence is palindromic but another
pattern that you must see is that it has
a single mode in the middle this happens
to be true for all the examples that we
and all other mathematicians in the
world I've tried but nobody knows how to
justify this and this is the unsolved
problem that I have tried to explain you
and it goes under the name the G
conjecture the G so G was the missing
letter and G is is the difference of the
HS 2 successive HS so the G here would
be 3 G here would be 2 and the G
conjecture
says that for every I GI is non-negative
which is another way of saying that the
H vector increases that leads up to the
middle weakly increases weakly increases
so it it is possible for example in this
sequence here one one one one one
it doesn't strictly increase but still
the G vector is non-negative and the
reason why I like this conjecture is
that you can do the experiment fairly
concretely as we have done right now
an explicit example so whenever you come
up with a new way to triangulate a
sphere you have your chance to disprove
this conjecture there another reason why
I love this conjecture is that not only
is very elementary and concrete it
actually predicts a very deep analog
with several different parts of
mathematics